[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi and
welcome to episode number 90
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing
exceptionally well today.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I am doing
pretty good, pretty good,
last part before I
go on my holiday.
So pretty excited
about that actually.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I'm pretty excited
about you going on holidays,
too, actually, I have to--
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Not seeing you for a couple
weeks, that's what I live for.
Also very happy
because we finally
got to be joined by
Greg DeMichillie.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
I'm so excited.
I've wanted him on the podcast
for a really long time.
And it really,
really, really makes
me happy to have him
here to come talk
to us about Office of the CTO.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I like better
of the name "Octo--" O-C-T-O.
OCTO, it sounds, I don't know,
like the villain of a James
Bond movie, Octo.
[LAUGHTER]
I like it.
MARK MANDEL: I like it.
I feel like there should be a
lair somewhere with a mountain.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Also,
at the end, we'll have--
I'm going to
mispronounce his name.
But I'm going to say
his name is "Ee-ta-mar"
but it may be "Eye-ta-mar."
Hi, Eye-ta-mar, Ee-ta-mar, sorry
for mispronouncing your name.
He sent a bunch of
Kubernetes questions.
And by a bunch, I mean a bunch.
We got one of them,
and we're going
to be answering it today, which
is, OK, "so I'm on the go.
I just have access
to my mobile phone.
How do I access the
Kubernetes dashboard?
Can do that?
And if so, how?"
So we'll talk about
that at the end.
But before that, we have
our Cool Things of the Week.
And I'm going to let you start.
MARK MANDEL: So
I'm going to start
from the bottom of
our list and go up.
Maybe that's fun.
But we've had Postgres
or PostgreSQL support
in beta on Cloud SQL here
at Google Cloud Platform
for a little while.
What's been really great is
we've got a bunch of feedback,
both on our issue tracker
as well as the discussion
group that we'll link
in the show notes,
about how people
are using Postgres
and what sort of
extensions and features
they want to have enabled
in the managed solution
that we're running.
What's been great
about that is we've now
enabled 19 different extensions
across four categories,
including stuff for geographic
locations, a variety
of new data types, enhanced
functionality for new
processing languages,
as well as, like,
some miscellaneous stuff around
tech search, cryptography,
integer aggregations, and
like a whole bunch of stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: We'll link
to the blog post, which
was written by our boss Greg
Wilson, a developer advocacy
lead.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, Greg.
MARK MANDEL: Hi, Greg.
I hope you're listening.
And also to the
documentation that
shows you all the
interesting little bits that
actually have been now enabled.
So please go try those out.
And if there's also other stuff
that you want to see available
that you usually
use on Postgres,
please feel free to add
stuff to the issue tracker
or the discussion group.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
have a stupid question
about this, which is, how do
you pronounce this database?
Do you pronounce it Postgres
Q-L, Post-grees See-quel?
MARK MANDEL: I tend
to just say Postgres.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
OK.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's what--
I don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know,
because the S is capital.
Anyway, so let's go
with the second thing
of the week, which I'm going
to choose to be, ooh, this one.
This one is cool.
The Met, the Metropolitan
Museum in New York,
they created an open data set
that is available on BigQuery.
And they have 375,000
images of public domain
from their collection, which
is under Creative Commons 0.
So that's a lot of images
that you can play with.
And if you're
interested in doing
like image processing, machine
learning, all of these things,
they're all available
for you right now.
So I'd say go play with them.
Also, if you like
art, which you should,
you can also go and see the
art, because they're also
really beautiful.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, I'm going to
take the Clojure
one, which is kind of cool
because I know you put this up.
But I'm going to steal
it because it's great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know.
I put it for you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
So on the "Circle
CI" blog, there
is an article talking
about Clojure, Clojure
with a J, a language that
I used to write a lot of
and still quite like, talking
about continuously deploying
Clojure apps to
Google App Engine,
and specifically Google
App Engine Flexible.
It's a super
interesting article,
I think, from two
perspectives, even
if you don't write Clojure.
One of which is they use
the Flexible environment
and build their own
Dockerfile for it.
So if you're interested
to see like if there
is a language that isn't
necessarily supported right
out the box how you can go about
doing that, as well as setting
it up so that it is
continuously deployed, such
that once you push something
to your repository,
it goes all the way through
and ends up on App Engine.
So it's a super cool article.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And it is for App Engine
Flexible or Standard?
MARK MANDEL: Flexible, yes.
It's flexible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, because
App Engine Standard now
should also support Clojure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you can
do it from what I understand.
There are steps
that you either need
to have Gradle or Maven build.
If you're doing
Clojure, then you're
probably not necessarily
using those toolings.
So there's a bit more
complexity there.
You could probably also
do the same thing, though.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Follow-up question,
were you ever as big
in the Clojure
community as you were
in the ColdFusion community?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: No.
No.
It's relative.
[LAUGHTER]
I think I was definitely bigger
in the ColdFusion community.
Yes, it's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Big fish small
pond, something like that.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
Something like that, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we're going to go
over the last Cool
Thing of the Week, which
is a cool thing of the week
because it means that
you're going to save money.
You can attach local
Solid-State Disks, SSDs.
So you can attach them to any
kind of Google Compute Engine
instance.
And before it had
the same price,
no matter what kind of instance
you were attaching it to.
Now, whenever you're
attaching them
to either on-demand or
preemptible instances,
they will be way,
way, way cheaper.
To the point that if
you're attaching them
to an on-demand instance,
it will be 63% less
than what it was before.
And for preemptible instances,
it's 71% cheaper than before.
It is a huge discount.
So if you're doing things
like running MapReduce
of bad jobs, where you need
a lot of really fast storage,
you can use local SSDs
with preemptible machines.
And it's going to be incredibly
affordable now, so yay.
MARK MANDEL: Yay,
price lower, good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I like it.
It's simple.
It's cheaper.
Like it better.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
Wonderful.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go out
with our now good friend Greg
DeMichillie and
talk all about OCTO.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
Let's go there.
MARK MANDEL: So
I'm really, really,
really excited to have
someone on the podcast
that I've wanted to have on the
podcast for a really, really
long time, Greg DeMichillie,
Director of Product Management
Cloud CTO Office.
Greg, how are you doing today?
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
I'm doing great.
I'm flattered that you
wanted to have me on here.
I've been listening for a while.
So I'm just happy to be here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's been
a long time, so thank you.
Thank you so much for joining.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
So we got you in today.
We want to talk
about OCTO, what it
is, what that relationship's
like with the customer.
Before we do that,
can you tell us
a little bit about what you do
with Google, like your history?
Like, what do you do here?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Sure.
So I've been at Google now
just around five years.
I used to say I joined Google
Cloud Platform before there
was a Google Cloud Platform.
When I joined, we had App Engine
and BigQuery and App Engine
and BigQuery.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: No Datastore?
Was there no Datastore then?
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Well, we had Datastore.
I always think of that as
really being-- at that point,
Datastore was only
usable from App Engine.
So I sort of think of it as one.
I'm still the hold over that
forgets that Datastore now
actually can be used
from any product.
So yeah, I started back
at the beginning of GCP.
For the first few years,
I led product management
for the compute side, so
App Engine, Compute Engine,
Kubernetes, the billing
system, the tools, the SDKs,
that sort of stuff.
And then as we've grown,
it's just been amazing.
And about, well, I guess,
a year ago, we saw,
with Diane Green joining
to run the organization,
we saw this huge increase in the
number of really big customers,
brands that anybody out there
would recognize that wanted
to talk about Google Cloud.
And they needed
somebody, or a group
of people, who were technical.
I mean, I'm an engineer
by training, right?
In between this meeting,
I was compiling TensorFlow
from sources on my
laptop a couple of hours
ago to get one
that was optimized
for my particular processor.
So I'm an engineer at heart.
But I've done this
long enough that I also
understand what businesses and
enterprises and C-level execs
think and want.
And so I view my role and I
view the CTO's office role,
it's really two ways.
I mean, you know like you guys,
you're developer advocates.
Your job is to advocate for
Google to developers but then
also to do the reverse,
right-- to advocate
for those developers
back to Google?
MARK MANDEL: Mm-hm.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: I kind of
view my job is the same thing.
Except instead of
developers, my job
is to advocate for these
senior executives at some
of these big companies, right?
And just like you
don't think about one
product-- you think about
the whole platform--
it's kind of the same.
I don't think about just data
storage, just machine learning,
or just Compute Engine.
I spend time with
those customers.
And then I try to
help the product
teams across the
whole suite understand
that set of customers and
understand what they care about
and their pain points.
So I really think it's
very similar to Dev Rel,
except it's not aimed at
individual developers.
It's aimed at the
C-level executive,
the senior technical people
in their organizations.
And it's fun because it means
in the morning my day might
be one part meeting with
some SVPs of a customer
or a potential customer.
It might be sitting in on a
tech review for a new upcoming
release of a product.
And then in between,
like I said,
I was compiling TensorFlow
from sources a little bit
earlier today.
So it's kind of fun to
be able to do all that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So all
of this kind of reminds me
of previous episodes we've done
lately on customer engineers
and customer
reliability engineers
and all of these people that
are kind of different kinds
of contacts to Google Cloud.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Mm-hmm.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How
are you different
or how are you similar
to like, for instance,
let's say, like strategic
customer engineers?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: So I
mean the thing to remember
is that when you're dealing with
a company that's as big as, you
know, HSBC or a company
as big as, you know,
Snapchat or Spotify,
they're filled
with people at every level.
They have people who
want to talk to somebody
who can write code for them.
They also want to
talk with people who
can think about the business.
So one difference is,
the main difference
is sort of who we interact
with in the organization.
So we tend to spend most
of our times with SVPs,
the CIO, the CTO, the
directors of engineering,
and those sorts of things.
We view our job is to sort
of be an advisor to them.
We're not in sales.
And I think that's kind of
an important distinction.
Like you, we're part of
the engineering team.
And so those sorts of
customers like having
someone they can talk
to that they know
is focused on the long term.
Like, my job isn't to retire
quota for the sales team
this quarter, right?
My job is to think about
the two-year journey
this customer is on and to try
to optimize for the long term.
And so that's-- and it's
helpful that we just are
in engineering, right?
We're that much closer to
the product development team.
But it's a horrible cliche
of it takes a village.
But there's truth to it, right,
in that a customer like this
needs technical
account managers.
They need customer engineers.
They need-- any
big company needs
a lot of help and assistance.
When you're talking
about something
as big as you know
abandoning your data center
and moving to the
cloud, right, that's
a huge change for
a company to make.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So you mentioned
some really big names,
like HSBC, Snapchat, which
is kind of funny that they're
both in the same sentence
because they're
so, so different.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Isn't that true?
That's what makes
the job fun, though.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is very amazing.
Of those customers, can
you talk a little bit
about what kind of customers
we're working with.
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Yeah, so obviously
I can talk about the
ones that are public.
One of the fun
things about the job
is, like you, we get involved
with customers sometimes
really, really early.
And for me, the fun
is the breadth of it.
I like one minute we're working
with the Walt Disney Company,
and you're talking
about, I mean, the people
who build the theme park I grew
up going to as a kid, right?
Then it might be Spotify.
And what a really cool company,
with thinking about how
to revolutionize music.
And then it'll be
a bank suddenly.
And, OK, now you've got to
switch your head to thinking
about the way a bank works.
Actually, it gives me-- it's
a good point to talk about is
the CTO office is--
it's a fairly large team.
And I would say one
part of the team
are people like me,
fundamentally technologists
who've been at Google
a reasonably long time
and who understand
the whole product mix.
But the other part are
Brian Stephens, our CTO,
uses this great phrase.
He calls them "recovering CTOs."
That is they're former CTOs of
companies like GE Manufacturing
or an oil and gas company.
So they come in
with this really "I
understand this
vertical market."
I mean, in some
ways I think of them
as like a universal translator.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, we speak
containers, and they
speak hydrogeological
analysis, right?
They can translate technology
speak into the language
of an industry.
So part of the fun
things about the job
is I get to work
with people who have
all sorts of really interesting
kind of crazy backgrounds.
And they aren't just kind of
engineering people like me,
but they're also people who
come from an oil-and-gas
or a finance or a
manufacturing background.
And so that means that
we work with companies
all over the board
and worldwide.
So for me, that's the
fun part of the job.
Even as an individual
engineer, I liked the demo.
I liked showing off what
you'd built to somebody.
Do you know what I mean?
Like when you build
something cool
and you show it to a
customer or a user,
and you see them go,
oh, wow, that's neat.
That, to me, was always the
really fun part of the job.
So in some ways now, I get
nothing but the fun part.
You know what I mean?
So it's perfect for me.
MARK MANDEL: No, that
sounds very interesting.
So I guess that
means then-- like you
were talking about people
who have verticalized.
So maybe if you're working with,
like, a large banking customer,
you might go in to talk
about the broader picture,
but you might also
bring in, say,
if there's somebody has a
verticalized title for finance
within OCTO as well.
So you have that sort
of team coming in.
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Well, and that's also--
you made a good point.
You talk about bringing
other people in.
OCTO does not have a
monopoly on smart people.
And so part of our job is to
know folks like you and folks
like the PM team and
the engineering team.
So if we're having a
conversation with somebody
and it turns out somebody
in their organization really
needs to understand,
I don't know,
how the Kubernetes scheduler
works or something like that,
we draw on the rest of the
product and the engineering
team.
And the good news is most of the
product and engineering people
I talk to, a chance to go sit
down with a real customer?
I mean, that's gold.
When you're building
products that
are used by thousands
or millions of people,
sometimes it can be
hard because it's
easy to get divorced and
separated from the actual user
because you don't know them.
But if you take an engineer
and you have them sit there
in a white board with-- like,
one of our network engineers
sits on a whiteboard with a
network operator at Spotify.
And they sketch
problems out together.
That sticks.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, that encounter
sticks with that person.
And when they go back and do
the rest of their development,
they will think about
that particular customer
they talked to.
So we also try to
really connect the dots
where we can so that
the engineers get
that sort of direct interaction
when it makes sense.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm curious.
As a customer of
Google Cloud platform,
what should I expect from
the office of the CTO?
Would you say it's just
a first point of contact
for them to figure
everything out,
or what does it [INAUDIBLE]?
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Yeah, that's important.
That's a good point.
We're-- Google Cloud Platform
is obviously large and growing.
We have a lot of
different customers.
The CTO office doesn't
scale in that sense, right?
Even with a team
of 40, do the math.
That's not big enough to
support 1,000 customers.
So we have a bit of a process
to determine where we engage.
It's largely driven by the
needs of the product teams
and the needs of
the sales teams.
Our primary focus is on those,
call it, the 500, 1,000,
the biggest companies, the
biggest brands and not just
by revenue, but in terms of
their brand and their brand
value.
Obviously, there are
certain customers
that if we bring them
onto the platform,
they tell a great story
that helps other customers.
So we have a bunch of different
criteria for what we look at.
The sad part is we can't
engage with every customer
that we would want to.
There's just not enough of us.
So unfortunately, we have to
do a little a bit of a triage.
The good news is,
though, the other part
of the job that I
really enjoy is many
of us are very active at
things like Google Cloud
Next and the summits.
We were very big in
the New York one.
I obviously went
to San Francisco.
I'm getting ready to go to
Google Cloud Summit in Sydney--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Me too.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: And I'll be
in Paris and, I think, Munich.
So if you come to
those events, that's
also a chance to
interact with us
and to get some
advice and guidance
and just talk to us about
Google Cloud and how that works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: This makes
me think about during Cloud
Next in San Francisco,
there was actually
a special track for these kind
of most important or strategic
customers.
Is that something
that you also do, or--
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah, we
work very closely with that.
There's these things called
leaders circle that we run,
sort of--
I don't want to say in parallel.
But the attendees are invited
by Google to come to this.
They're usually the
more senior executives.
They will go to the keynotes.
And then they'll
come to-- instead
of going to the
engineering code breakouts,
they go to their own sort
of set of breakouts that
talk about some business
issues and business strategy
and that sort of stuff.
So, yeah, we're very
involved in those.
And again that's another
fun opportunity for us
to sort of understand
what's going on
or what these customers
actually need from us.
So I love that part of the job.
Again, Next and Summit
and those sorts of things,
I think that's the
fun part, right,
to actually get out
and talk to people
and show what you've done.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, now
I'm quite curious as well.
As you say, you've got a
long history of engineering.
What do you find are the
big differences between sort
of working with-- like, I know
we're developer advocates.
We work at a developer level.
You work at probably like
more of a CXO kind of level.
What do you find that
big difference there
in terms of like
the expectations
or what people are looking for
out of either GCP or from you
as the office of CTO?
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Well, I mean, first
what's the same is you
have to be grounded
in technical reality, right?
I can't do my job
if I don't have
some understanding of
how TensorFlow works
and how Kubernetes works.
And I don't have any code
contributions that have ever
been pushed into those repos.
I don't think I ever will.
But it starts with you
have to be grounded
in a technical reality.
Because at the end of
the day, the customer's
buying technology from
you, and they want to know,
does it work?
Will it work to
solve their problems?
And so it starts
with, just like you,
that same grounded
in reality part.
What's different
is my slide decks
don't really have
code samples anymore.
But they have
technical material.
I do talk about things
like spanner scaling.
Or I do talk about things
like machine learning,
training and how much
compute do you need.
How much data is enough to
build a decent ML model.
It is technical, but I don't
have code samples and APIs
in my slides anymore.
My demos aren't opening up
an IDE and editing code.
They're slightly different.
But what stays the
same is you have
to be grounded in the
technical truth in reality,
because otherwise you're
not helping, right?
You're just selling.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that makes sense.
The other thing I was
curious about as well
is what does an engagement with
the office of CTO look like?
I know like Cs
obviously-- obviously
Cs have, like, regular
meetings and stuff like that.
Is it the same for
Office CTO as well?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah,
it's a good point.
First, it's important
to understand
we usually are involved early
on in the early process.
And then we usually phase
out a bit once the customer
is fully onboard.
Where we really try
to help is there's
that point when the customer's
trying to get their sea
legs under them.
Do you know what I mean?
They know they want
to be on the cloud.
They know it's different.
They don't quite
necessarily know
which project should be
their first project, which
should be their second.
So we're very intensely involved
in that sort of early phase.
Once the customer's really
ramped up and in production
and they know Google Cloud
Platform really well,
then our interaction
phases out, because now
the strategic customer
engineers, all the rest
of Google's technical
team can help them work
with that customer over time.
So we tend to be very involved
in sort of early-on phases
and then phasing out a bit.
We stay in touch with
them because we also
run our customer advisory boards
and those sorts of things.
So we stay in touch with them.
But the depth of the engagement,
instead of being on the phone
or on GVC once a week or
flying out to London, which
in the early
phases, we literally
will be talking with someone
at one of these companies once
a week, multiple times a week,
it eventually phases out,
and it becomes more of a
checking in periodically.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And it sounds like you've helped
a lot with some fairly large
migrations into the cloud.
Have there been any
particular lessons
you've learned along the way
that maybe our listeners might
want to be interested in?
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
I think right now
there's a lot of
block-and-tackle work
of migrating data and security
and all those sorts of things.
But I think the biggest
one, I would say,
is when I look at companies
that migrate really quickly
and versus companies
that take a long time,
often the difference isn't
so much in the technology
of the company.
It's in the approach
the company takes.
The companies that
move fast, move fast
because there is
one or more leader
in the company who's committed
to making it happen fast.
Because, look, there'll
be hiccups along the way.
And companies that
move fast, they
don't allow everything
to grind to a halt
when they hit that first hiccup.
They sit there and say,
OK, we've got to solve it.
Let's move that to the side.
Let's get some smart
people on it solving it.
But let's keep everything
else moving forward.
The companies that
take a long time,
sometimes that
stuff's like Velcro,
and you get stuck on it.
You know what I mean?
And so the companies
that take longer,
often it's because everything
starts to sort of slow down
when you hit the inevitable
issues or hiccups.
And everybody-- I mean,
companies are big.
This stuff's complicated.
But I think that's probably
the biggest difference
is you can move quickly.
But as an organization,
you have to sort of
be committed to that, that
we're going to move quickly.
When we hit
problems, we're going
to figure out how to
not side track them,
but work on them without
everything else grinding
to a halt. And that,
to me, is the pattern
I see when you see
the companies that
have really been fast moving.
The other thing is pick a
pilot project and just start.
Like, some companies
won't start anything
until they know everything.
And you'll never know
everything, right?
Pick a pilot.
That pilot will teach you so
much about how the cloud works
and the APIs and the consoles.
You'll learn 10 times as much
out of that first pilot project
as your second one, because it's
when you're learning everything
about how all these
pieces fit together.
So it's credibly valuable.
So I really encourage people to
do that as early as they can,
because you'll come out
of that with so much more
knowledge about how all
these things work together.
So, yeah, be committed
to it and know
that you're going
to have issues,
and be committed to not letting
those make everything stop.
Find a pilot.
Start a pilot.
Get something so you get your
sea legs under you, right?
And it's not quite so
much of a strange world.
And that approach,
when we see that,
that's when we see customers
that end up moving really fast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you were
saying customers that move fast
versus customers that slow.
How fast is fast?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Well, I don't
remember the exact number,
but the Evernote, I think, is
a pretty remarkable example
of how quickly they moved
from there on-perm environment
to Google Cloud, including
petabytes of data.
And as you might
imagine with Evernote,
they wanted to make sure
they were really satisfied
with security of their
customers' information
and all those sorts of things.
I think they were an example.
Lush Cosmetics in
the UK, I think
the number was 28 days or
something like totally insane.
I'd have to go back and look.
They were on stage at
Next in San Francisco,
and they talked about the
speed with which they moved.
So, yeah, these
things can be done
in order of a month or
two, if you're committed,
and if you're all hands
on deck in that way.
And so Evernote and
Lush were two examples
of companies who just did
it really, really quickly.
Now, that doesn't mean everybody
can do it that quickly.
But again, in those
companies, they just--
they were committed to it.
They had an attitude
of we're going
to work through the
problems as they come up.
And we like that.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, I think one of the
things that customers
that work with us find
is that at Google, I
think for all of
us, we really do
think of this as a
partnership with the customer.
We don't want to build
software, throw it
over the wall to the customer,
good luck figuring it out.
We really want to have
an engineer-to-engineer
relationship with
these customers.
And I find they appreciate
that, and that's another reason
they can move fast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I think
that that is a common theme
over all the episodes we've
been doing with CRE and CE
and [INAUDIBLE] and
all of those E's.
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Yeah, it's just,
even if you're in a
customer-facing role,
we hire for people
who just are, I
would say, an engineer at heart.
And by that I mean
likes solving problems.
You know what I mean?
That like technology, that
think this stuff is just cool,
and that's certainly me and you.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
have one last question.
We're almost
running out of time.
But I have one more question.
You mentioned that the
speed at which companies
are able to move to the
cloud depends mostly
on their willingness
or like how ready they
are as an organization to move.
Is that for companies that
are doing basically, like, I
think it's lift and shift?
Or is it more like
are they rewriting
some of their components?
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Yeah, obviously that's
a big variable.
Obviously that is.
If you're just taking
an existing system--
and obviously, no two
companies are alike.
If you have a mainframe, things
are more complicated, right?
If you have SPARC
stations or other sorts
of strange hardware--
so I don't I
don't mean to say every
customer, if they just
willed it, could
move in the speed
that Lush or Evernote did.
But I would say that
even large companies
can have significant work
going on in the cloud
if they want to.
So that's not the same as saying
you've completely shut down
your data center, and
you're completely--
because, again, large
customers have large systems.
But you can but you
can start to move now.
Do you know what I mean?
I think Eric Schmidt
said that at Cloud Next.
Like, get to the cloud now.
That doesn't mean get
out of everything now.
But it means start now.
And this just comes up
over and over again.
Customers are fascinated
by artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
And my message to them
is the same thing.
Start investing now.
This is a different
way to program.
This is a different way to think
about application development.
You need to start now,
because you need to develop
the technical skills.
You need to understand what
it is you're trying to do.
So, yeah, I think Eric
Schmidt had it right.
It almost doesn't
matter your industry.
You can start now.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, we are unfortunately
running out of time here.
But before we wrap
up, is there anything
you want to make sure we
mention or you want to plug,
or is there just
something cool that you
want to talk about that you want
to make sure is on the podcast?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: I
mean, I would just
say keep coming to the Cloud
Next and the Cloud Summit
events.
We're-- right up to this
meeting, I'm going to go.
We're talking about
some new demos
we're going to hopefully unveil
at some of the future Cloud
Summits.
I love talking to
customers there.
And it's a great opportunity
to come and meet with the dev
rel, the PMs, the engineers, the
customer engineers, the people
who built this technology.
And I always say
about these events,
if you go to a
conference and all you
do is sit in the sessions,
you've missed the real value.
The real value is the
hallway conversations
that you can have.
And so sign up for--
we're coming to Sydney,
Singapore, Kuala Lumpur,
Bangalore, Mumbai, Munich,
Stockholm, Paris, Seattle,
Chicago.
So we're coming all
over the world--
Sao Paolo, Mexico City.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Amsterdam.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG DEMICHILLIE:
Did I forget any?
I'm visualizing the
spreadsheet in my head.
MARK MANDEL: That
was impressive.
That was pretty good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
many of them, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG DEMICHILLIE: No,
really, come to those events.
In one day, it's
a great way to get
a sense of not just where
Google Cloud Platform is,
but where we're
going and a chance
to talk with the people
who are building it
and to have a voice
in shaping that.
So I'm big believers in those.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
We'll make sure to have a bunch
of links in the show notes
to all of those events,
if you want to attend.
So make sure that you
check it out and register.
And other than that,
thank you so much,
Greg, for taking the
time today to talk
a little bit about OCTO.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah,
it was my pleasure.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks
again to Greg DeMichillie
for coming and joining
us today to tell us
a little bit about
OCTO, what they do,
and in general, for just
hanging out with us.
He's a pretty cool guy.
So thanks for spending
time with us today.
He mentioned at some point
that the Lush migration
from on premise to the cloud,
he thought it was 28 days.
But at the end of
the interview, he
was like, hey, make
sure this is not
too little, because
I'm not completely
sure on the exact number.
So we checked, and he
was actually wrong.
It was not 28 days.
It was 22, which--
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: It's just less.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
which is even faster,
which is pretty crazy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In 22
days, they actually migrated
from on premise to Google Cloud
Platform-- pretty impressive.
MARK MANDEL: That's crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
now I guess it's time
to go with the
Question of the Week.
Thanks, Mark, for confirming
that the name is actually
pronounced It-a-mar and
not Eye-ta-mar or anything
like that.
[LAUGHTER]
So thanks, Itamar,
for your questions,
because you sent
a bunch of them.
We decided to go with
the last one you sent,
which is about is there a way to
access the Kubernetes dashboard
without running kubectl proxy?
And the context
is, for instance,
if I wanted to do
something quickly
on the road from a mobile phone.
So what do you think?
Is there a way to do this?
MARK MANDEL: This is an
interesting question.
I think the answer is kind
of no-ish, because reasons.
So let's kind of
walk through them.
So generally speaking, if
you want to access the UI--
so if you're not
familiar, Kubernetes
comes with a dashboard.
It gives you visualization
of what Kubernetes is doing.
But it also allows you
to sort of deploy stuff,
edit stuff, basically administer
your whole cluster if you
want to do it through UI.
Generally speaking, you want
to use the kubectl proxy.
Because that's going
to give you security.
That's the secure way.
You're going to log in
with your credentials.
And that's all
going to be set up
and work the way it should do.
In previous versions or
depending on your setup
for your Kubernetes proxy,
you could access the UI
through the IP address
of your master.
OK, it works.
Generally, though,
I think you'll
find on newer versions
of Kubernetes that
weren't work nearly
as well or it just
won't work at all because things
like RBAC and things like that.
So you have policies that say
what you can access from where.
I think that's probably a
good thing, because you really
don't want like people from
outside of the world accessing
your master.
That's pretty bad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because
the dashboard is not only
a dashboard in the
point of read only.
You can actually
delete stuff, right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, you can delete pods.
You can edit like your
YAML file configurations.
Like, you could basically do
whatever you like in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Maybe even
access secrets, so, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
If you wanted to
access stuff or like
see what was going on from
your phone, unfortunately,
right now you don't have access
to Cloud Shell from your phone.
But I would say you
could fire up a small VM,
login SSH into that
from your phone,
and run kubectl
commands, and still
be able to see what's going on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I checked.
And indeed, the
Android application
does not provide
a Cloud Shell yet.
But I pinged a PM, being
like, dude, come on.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: I reckon
we should have that.
That's my opinion.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Especially
because you can actually
access it through the web.
Like, you can actually visit
Console [INAUDIBLE] Cloud
at google.com come
from your mobile phone
and start Cloud
Shell from there.
But there's some
problem there, too,
and the typing does
not work that easily,
which means that at the end of
the day, kind of hard to use.
But the good thing
about Cloud Shell
is that you can also
do the port preview.
So you will be able to access,
as a web server, your Cloud
Shell, right?
And this is actually
totally secure,
because only if you're
signed in with your account,
you will be able to
access that port, which
means that you will be
able to use kubectl proxy
and access it securely.
Because otherwise,
if you do it the way
you were saying, if you
create a small instance
and you SSH into it, which you
can do from the Android app,
by the way, then the problem
is that then, yes, kubectl,
whatever, will work.
kubectl proxy will open a port.
But then you need to
open it from the outset.
And then anyone can access it.
So we go back to the
problem that anyone
could access your dashboard,
which is a really bad idea.
So I guess the answer
is don't do it?
MARK MANDEL: I would
say the answer then
is just open your laptop.
Use Cloud Shell to get in.
Then you can still
do on the road.
You don't need the tools
necessarily on that laptop.
And then you can continue
to work forward from there.
But I will say thanks so
much for this question.
It actually spent
a bunch of time
to be like what's going on?
Can we actually access
Cloud Shell from Android?
Like, what way could we do this?
And so it's great to
explore this stuff.
So please continue
to send questions.
We love them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, as a result,
I'll be filing two bugs.
So thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So Francesc, what are you up to?
I know you're going on holidays.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Is that
all you're up to?
Or have you got other things
that you want to talk about?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's basically
everything you want to
think about right now.
[LAUGHTER]
On top of that, I'm
also working on--
so I just released
"Just For Func"
episode on how to contribute to
the open source project, which
is really cool.
If you've not contributed
to an open source project,
Go is a very good
one to start with.
So check it out.
And then after that I
actually got the confirmation
that in September I
will be going to Sydney.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So very
excited about that one.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm about
to enter a crazy season.
So I will be at Play NYC doing
stuff about games, so Play NYC
in New York in a
couple of weeks.
Pax Dev, which will be in
Seattle on the 29th, Pax West,
shortly after
that, then Gameacon
a couple of weeks
after that, and then
Austin Game Conference about
a week after that, and then
Strange Loop about
a week after that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
That sounds intense.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: It's
going to be fun!
I'm already tired.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Other than that,
are you doing
something interesting?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Well,
people do keep
bugging me to keep
writing the Kubernetes
and game server series,
which I do want to do.
I've started writing
some more stuff
on the next version of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's a cool one.
Nice.
Well, I think it's almost
time to say goodbye.
But why not remind everyone
how to get in touch with us
so they can send
us more questions
or send us things
saying hi or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Like, we miss you.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, Francesc, are you
willing to give this a shot?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Whew, OK.
Let's try this.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
So there's a website.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: They can email us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
hello@gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: They can
reach us on Google+.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: On Reddit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In the
subreddit r/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: On Twitter.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: @gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: And on Slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think it's the Podcast Channel
in the CCP Community Channel,
yes?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So it is the
Podcast Channel on the Google
Cloud Platform Community
Slack, which you can reach
on bit.ly/gcp/slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One
day I will learn that.
Thanks, Mark, for such
an awesome episode
and for remembering
how to join Slack.
MARK MANDEL: And thanks
to everyone for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]